Trying to figure out how certain traits are inherited can
be really difficult. Sometimes we have a trait like one
of our parents or the other, and other times we
may have a trait not like our parents at all.
Take these three examples of families with different traits. For
example, look at height in the first scenario. We have
two parents who are relatively short. Will have a son
that's taller than both of them. Much taller, in fact.
We have a family where the parents have a daughter
and a little baby. And they all share the same
skin color, roughly speaking. And in this third family, we
have one parent who has a disposition of being happy
all the time. And the other parent has a disposition
of being sad all the time. Both the daughter and
the son have a disposition of being happy. What I
want you to tell me, is does the indicated trait appear
related to one or both of the parents at all? For
example, in the case of height, I want you to compare the
son to the parents. And see if it appears that in some
form or fashion whether it's a combination of the parents or one
of the parents sharing this trait, does the son appear related with
regards to this particular trait of height. And the same thing in
the scenario with skin color and the same thing with the scenario
we set up for disposition. Go ahead and tell me which answer
you think is best for each case.